yeah but if you call Magnus you probably
won't yeah but look at this okay white
has another Pawn in his pocket oh right
they much fall together torturous we
talked about the pawns The Rook the
night all of them now combining in
harmony together and next move the white
Pawn is going to step up check against
the black king and White's gonna make a
new Queen it's game over now
wow I hope I've been up on the actually
look at Magnus as well he knows it he
knows he's got it wow unbelievable I
mean you can sell that you know you
should never relax until it's over but
he's just taking a bit of a cider and
this is uh and it's been an incredible
game and then that classic Magnus
Carlson fashion as well people have
questioned his motivation is he still
the same and he plays for seven hours
and 45 minutes everyone's saying this is
a draw and he clinches it yeah yeah this
last move is so classy I've got to say
it by Magnus he's allowing checks but
he's gonna run with the white king all
the way in front of the White Knight
he's gonna March his King the whole way
up the board to sit in front of the
White Knight for him and no more checks
and the white porn will be making your
queen beautiful I have a question Final
Touch so so sophisticated and no stale
mates nothing question for you both is
this the type of loss that is maybe
gonna cause
to tilt to crumble yeah I think this is
devastating you know one who would not
be upset after this this is incredible
you were winning you were drawing it's a
long game you're tired he played really
well yeah I mean this this could crush a
lot of people it's gonna be so
interesting to see in the next two days
now tomorrow yeah and Sunday yeah we
have our first win back there we go
the first decided game and we hear
Applause from Dubai Magnus Carlsen the
world champion in game six that always
ends up with drama